Another study Bandura did focused on reinforcing the observed behavior. Bandura
put children in to four groups. Group one saw a video with no models. Group two
saw two adult males interacting in a nonaggressive way. Group three and group
four saw two adult males playing with one of the males being aggressive.
However in group three, the aggressive one was punished. And in group four, the
aggressive one was rewarded. The first two groups are what we would consider
the control groups. In group three and group four were the experimental groups.
The results show that the kids in the two experimental groups were more
aggressive than the kids in the control groups. However, the kids who saw the
adult being rewarded were even more aggressive than anyone else. This proves
that we not only learn from other people's behavior, we also take into account
the consequences of other people's behavior. And those consequences would be
either punishment or the reward.